yeah guys we're talking icarly which is
back for a second season this friday on
paramount plus the new episodes there
are ten of them pick up after the events
of carly's love triangle in the finale
and it teases a surprise drake and josh
cameo let's take a look now all hands in
on three one two three
he probably should have gone over it
before i'm in a hot
hot relationship wait
with who
what a rude question
did you want icarly to be the most
successful web series in history or did
you want it to just be like a massive
failure i mean probably the most
successful web series in history duh
we're going out
are those unicorn pajamas
did you see he's dabbing damn
what does it mean to you that this is a
show that when the first season of the
reboot came out people were like yes
this is the way to do it it's followed
the core tone of the original but it's
allowed the characters to mature
um it felt great to get you know such
positive feedback from the first season
because we were all really nervous the
day it came out we really made the show
for the original fans and it's just nice
that those people grew up with us and
that they still like the show today yeah
have you heard from fans who watched it
when they were younger who said you guys
are totally nailing my life yeah i mean
sometimes i'll be out and people will
come up and say like you know you were
my childhood because i watched the show
like when i was little and people really
do feel like they grow up alongside us
this is what i'm talking about let's
hear the love yeah
it's also just crazy because i grew up
on the icarly set i started when i was
13 and we finished the show when i was
20 the original run so it's just so
weird to be there as a full adult now
and just kind of get to experience it in
a new way we've been waiting years for
you two to get together
we got a little bit of tease in the
trailer josh peck is joining you guys
he's playing carly's manager what was it
like getting back on set with him it was
so much fun getting to work with josh
again he was when i first met him i was
eight years old and it was for the last
audition for the show drake and josh
that i was on when i was little yeah and
he's just been such a big part of my
life ever since i was a kid so to get to
grow up and have him play carly's
manager on icarly and be in multiple
episodes this season it just kind of
felt like a full circle moment it begins
i thought it already began oh it's begun
is there any chance we're gonna get uh a
drake bell cameo on the show as well i
don't know but um you know i'm up for
anybody who used to be on hold series or
i try to get as many of my friends too
just to come on the show cause it's fun
it's just dinner's really important to
my dad he's trying to get a promotion
yeah well my band's show tonight is just
as important as your dad's dinner hey
he's your dad now too you know whatever
i feel like a lot was made about their
feud what's your take on this it just
seems to be perpetual every time there's
like a yeah yeah every time it's like oh
we're cool and then also now we're not
cool again and now we are i don't know i
kind of don't even really keep up with
all of it that much but um i'm just
super happy for for josh this is like a
book that just came out so yeah
i know the book very how much of the
book was a surprise to you were there
parts of it that you read and thought to
yourself like oh my god i never knew
this about him i mean there's a pretty
big confession about uh substance abuse
which i feel like
even people closest to him might not
know yeah i really didn't know um a lot
of the stuff that was in it so it was
kind of you know surprising and also
like just amazing everything that he's
done and overcome and
um i thought his story was like really
incredible yeah he talked interestingly
about um
not really able not really being able to
identify with the younger version of
himself until he was older did you have
any
any struggle with that as a you know
somebody who came to acting very very
young and grew up staying in the
business for sure just from going on a
lot of auditions of like starting at a
really young age i think that that
kind of does something a little weird
dude just because you're always trying
to play different characters and you're
also at the same time trying to figure
out who you are who you're growing up
yeah it's interesting because obviously
having been on tv for so long i think
people
see carly and think that that is you so
much so that when you were on uh whitney
cummings podcast and you swore that went
viral i mean what was your what was your
take on that i definitely didn't expect
that um i love whitney she's she's
really funny and when i went on her
podcast i was kind of i'm just not edgy
at all and it's so funny because the
thing that went viral is probably like
the wildest thing i said in the whole
podcast and i was trying to like be cool
with her and it turned into this whole
tick tock trend it did everybody got in
on it and we pulled some of our
favorites let's take a look and then
we'll talk about it i actually do cuss a
little do you also what's your favorite
curse word probably
i actually do cuss a little do you also
what's your favorite curse word probably
i actually do cuss a little do you also
what's your favorite curse word probably
[Laughter]
i mean lizzie
i love lizzo
which one of those was your favorite
well i'd have to probably go with josh
just because he's my friend and it
cracked me up that he did it but i love
them all joe jonas is great this i mean
this is is this going to be your tick
tock legacy i mean if it is i'll take it
let's talk about the kids choice awards
this weekend um you're going gonna be
hosting with bronc how do you wrangle
gronk's energy he's like a big kid
himself you think you've got the stamina
to pull off 1 000
wait how many yeah um i'm just i'm super
excited to get to do it with him because
he has awesome energy he's so game for
anything and even doing the promos with
him for the show was so much fun he got
slimed worse than anyone i've ever seen
get slimed my whole life
he has so much to learn which of the
presenters or performers that you can
talk about now that are you really
looking forward to seeing well i'm super
excited that kid cuddy and jack harlow
are performing and um i'm just excited
for the whole experience you're gonna
have a great time trust me um now before
we let you go obviously uh
school of rock is coming up on its 20th
anniversary um we spoke to jack black a
couple days ago and my best memories are
just
that group of kids
and how funny and great they were and
it's definitely the highlight of my
career i can say that honestly that
prompted us to go back and dig through
our footage to find some of your first
interviews with us oh my god so uh let's
take a look at that actually
oh no like in one of the scenes um when
he kicks over the desk and we're all
laughing that's all genuine like we're
actually laughing so they put a lot of
that in the movie which is really cool i
want you to give us your best jack black
impression
a face a sound a moment
he likes to do that a lot
what
what are you doing that that was so not
jack black in any way shape or form it's
pretty good do you have it like a memory
that stands out from
set that like yeah um
yeah i have so many memories um just
getting to go to new york for the first
time it was my first time going on a
plane getting when i was in the movie i
did it when i was nine years old um
first movie i've ever been in yeah have
you ever have you run into jack in the
since then yeah i've seen him he was
actually um in an episode of icarly uh
the original icarly oh yeah do you have
an updated jack black impression
if i do it like that what did i do i was
like
just
angry face at the camera it was very
strange
thank you so much i carly this week and
then the kids choice this uh this
weekend a lot going on congratulations
thanks so much thank you
you